i totally got that i was an obnoxiously
privileged kid
hello and welcome to the roast of your
teenage self podcast
i am your host your roast coming queen a
girl who took the
s.a.t two times and got the exact same
score elise morales and with us today
guys we have such an exciting guest i
would say
an icon of my teen years he's the host
of the wild ride podcast
you might know him from a show called
jackass but before all of that
he was a graduate of the american school
in london please welcome stevo
thank you i'm super excited to have you
on the podcast i
i mentioned it as we were coming in but
um when i was a teenager i was a big fan
of jackass and i had wild boys the dvd
box set
so you're kind of like nice goals guest
as far as this podcast goes
i appreciate that i did a little like
wikipedia of you
before we started and it seems like um
prior to high school you moved around
a ton uh so could you just kind of take
us through some of that
sure i was born in england
wimbledon to be precise
at the age of six months my family moved
to
brazil and i've spoke my first words in
portuguese
living in rio de janeiro brazil wow
i think i was two
when we moved to caracas venezuela
and i spoke fluent spanish in
nursery school and then
moved to america when i was four years
old
um yeah i went to connecticut
durian and um so when you get down to it
i spoke
three languages by the age of
uh like three or four and i forgot
two of those languages by the age of
five
so do you retain any do you have any of
them now apart from english
i was told that i spoke portuguese
in uh my sleep at a summer camp
that i went to when i was 11 years old
and i thought that was pretty cool but
overall no i have
no retention whatsoever
so what prompted all of them moving
like was it just one parent's job or
like
yeah how did you end up going from place
to place my dad worked for
international divisions of uh
multinational companies uh
when we moved to brazil was because dad
got the job of
president of pepsi cola in all of brazil
oh wow yeah and and when we moved
to uh caracas venezuela
it was because dad was promoted to
uh president of pepsi cola in
central america and then some larger
portion
of pepsi cola it was still pepsi when we
moved to connecticut
uh when i was six we moved to uh miami
and that was when dad became a big
tobacco
ceo he worked for wow rj
reynolds tobacco and
that this was of course in the early 80s
um by 1983
um it it was learned that
cigarettes were actually bad for you
and dad was a dad worked for big tobacco
and at that point the uh the the
tobacco companies sort of you know
sensing
that their world was crumbling around
them became uh
you know nervous and bought up food
companies
rj reynolds tobacco
uh merged with nabisco and
dad became the president of nabisco in
like the whole world i think
okay so are you aware that this is a big
deal at the time are you just like no
everybody's dad is the president of
nabisco or are you like
do you get that you're kind of wheeling
and dealing in the upper levels of
society here
i totally got that i was an obnoxiously
privileged kid
and um as i grew older my dad became
increasingly successful
uh my mom's alcoholism became more
chronic
the house got bigger you know my sister
bailed out the family got smaller
you know and uh dad was never home
anyway because he was always uh flying
around the world
you know doing his business stuff so it
was just me and my mom
and uh mom's alcoholism got so crazy
that it was just like going to school
became optional
you know like yeah so it's like you're
seeing
this kind of economic success that your
dad's having but it's not
translating to like happiness or success
in any way you're like
holding this at all oh god no god no and
i was and
and i was very self-conscious about it
i was very uncomfortable having any kids
from school come over to see this large
house
that we lived in um i just was i was
really kind of ashamed of it i actually
wanted to take a minute to
pull up your first photo so we've got
this one of you
um you're looking very young very
sweet but mischievous is the vibe that
i'm getting here
i was 13 years old in that picture i've
posted that picture to my social media
uh multiple times and
and every time that my caption for the
photo
is this was before any goo
came out which which to me is uh
pretty fascinating because uh that seems
like a kid that would be blowing a load
but i was i was i was firing blanks so
are you trying at this point or
like yeah i was i had figured out the uh
the the concept of uh of bringing myself
to climax
and nothing uh was actually um being
shot out
see that's the thing that i it's funny
to hear about that
from from boys because it's it's kind of
like the opposite way for girls like
boys get the information and then they
can't act on it for a little while
girls can kind of act on it forever but
they have to get the information
first about like how you even do it
right
how's that i was that photo was actually
taken when i lived in toronto
okay and in canada um and uh
we had this bathroom that opened out to
the to the pool and the idea was you
know you come in and
that the shower had a faucet that you
that was like just closer to the ground
to to rinse off your feet
i didn't know i just knew that when i
crawled into that faucet and put my
wiener under the water
that uh that it really like something
pretty cool happened
and that was my that was my introduction
to
to masturbation
today's episode of the roast of your
teenage self podcast is brought to you
by purple throw some bedding on a bunch
of different mattresses and sure
they all look alike the same goes for
pillows but peel
away the layers and look at what's
inside which in many ways
is what we do on this podcast every
single day
or every every tuesday you get what i
mean you'll
see that all pillows and mattresses
aren't created equal and that's
what makes every purple pillow and
mattress unlike anything you've
ever slept on and i've i've slept on
some weird stuff
okay college we don't get into really
college on this podcast but college was
this whole
a whole other thing the purple grit
that's purple mattresses apart from
every other mattress it's a patented
comfort technology that
instantly adapts to your body's natural
shape and sleep style
i actually receive a little sample
of the purple grid which i use i use as
a stress reliever
okay i'm i'm squeezing on that thing and
if and it feels good
and you can actually have that feeling
all over your body with over 1800
open-air channels designed to neutralize
body heat
purple provides a cooling effect other
mattresses can't replicate
should i go into the fact that i'm a hot
and sweaty sleeper again
should i keep talking about the fact
that
my fiance is like a heater that sleeps
next to me
and is on all the time and it's the
reason why i wake up sweaty
are this is this something you want to
hear about because it's true
but not with purple because purple's
cutting edge technology doesn't stop at
the mattresses
every purple pillow is engineered with
the grid for
total head and neck support and absolute
airflow
so you're always on the cool side
of the pillow purple's proprietary
technology has been innovating comfort
for over
15 years so in a way there purple is a
teenager
as well and you know i can really see
all of these all of these beautiful
things coming together with my gorgeous
purple pillow it's keeping me cool
it's keeping me sane it's keeping me
less sweaty how much sweat should i talk
about in this ad i'm just gonna move on
you can try every purple product
risk-free
with free shipping and returns and
purple has financing available as low as
zero percent apr
for qualified customers so you want to
like pay on a monthly schedule
times are tough things are crazy right
now you can still get a good night's
sleep and babe
don't you deserve it experience the
purple grid and you'll sleep like never
before go to purple.com
teen self 10 and use promo code
teen self 10 for a limited time and
you'll get
10 off any order of 200 or more
that's purple.com team self 10 promo
code teen self 10
for 10 off any order of 200
or more terms apply
in moving from school to school and
stuff
did you develop like a strategy for how
you were gonna
make friends at the new school what like
what was your like
day one of a new school team stevo walks
in what's your like first
move i was just this
this ball of energy this this uh
just super uncomfortable
like socially just
incompetent attention [ __ ] kid
and i wanted so much to to win the
approval of my peers and
and to impress them and and to you know
i had to be liked and everything that i
did
brought about the entirely opposite
results i just tried
so too hard i had a super uncomfortable
like i just really did not do well
socially
and where the family moved so often you
would think of that as like a trauma
a traumatic thing in my case the
the every time my parents told me
hey we're going to move again i was
thrilled to hear it
because i had created a just a terrible
situation for me in every school
and every time that i found out we were
going to move i thought
yes i get a whole new chance you know a
whole
clean fresh start and this time
i'm gonna be cool
i was so determined to like get it right
each time and every time
there i was everywhere i went there i
was
and was it just the trying that stopped
you like
it was kind of that catch-22 like the
least cool thing you can do is
try to be cool type of a deal i just
couldn't relax
i tried you know like i i tried so hard
and it was just like you kook you know
i couldn't help but be a kook
you know like i have this one story and
i know i've told it before but it's just
like
it characterizes what i was like uh
in fifth grade like one of my final
uh like baby teeth i
i you know it was one of my last ones
and it was just
barely felt like it was loose and uh
and i knew already from that time
because i was big on
getting money from the tooth fairy river
that i wanted to rip it out and if i
ripped it out
prematurely that there would be a lot of
blood
so so i went into my spanish class that
day with this plant i thought
and i remember sitting next to
the prettiest girl in the class which
under normal circumstances i just would
never have done
and like and and just with this like
crazy conference i sat right next to her
and i told her
i don't have to be in class today i can
leave
whenever i want you know and she like
kind of looked at me like i was a kook
and like you're weird what the [ __ ] are
you talking about
and then when the class started i i i
just reached in and i just grabbed this
tooth and just
super violently ripped it out oh my god
and uh
and sure enough there was tons of blood
like
and i raised my hand said to the teacher
like i have to go to the nurse and the
teacher could just see all this blood in
my mouth and the teacher said go
go go to the nurse and i stood up
proudly turned to the girl and said i
told you so and i just and i just
marched out of the class and paraded
around the school
through the hallway and like i
felt so cool when in fact i mean
was she impressed did it work
no like not at all that's that's what i
was like as a kid
you know and i remember it was like you
know everyone get around check it out
this is going to be awesome and i would
take uh
i remember i don't know like i would i
know i did it one time in the cafeteria
i got all the kids to gather around and
i unscrewed a salt shaker and just like
consumed all this i just drank all the
salt out of it
website is not good for you it did the
kids were not impressed
and my parents as usual got a call
had you know like i was in trouble
and that's what the kind of thing i
would try to do to to win
uh influence and affection you know well
it's interesting to me because
it did it didn't work on your peers at
the time
but i will say that when i
was watching and i was a teenager we
were all extremely impressed and we
thought it was very cool
it worked eventually thank you yeah the
uh
everything that made my childhood
terribly uncomfortable
and uh traumatic did end up working out
to some degree so i think we actually
have another picture where
it looks like you're jumping off of a
roof there we go
so how far were your antics
going in high school were you like
reaching the same level as you
eventually would
on the show or was it were you just
dipping your toe in i mean clearly here
you're jumping off of a roof
so yeah that one in in this picture
i'm 19 years old this was before
eminem was a thing and i hadn't had my
hair bleached
you did it first you heard of your first
guys
what's interesting about that picture is
that my mom took it
she's really cool you know yeah it's
like yeah
and it's her house like yeah jump off
the house like um
and and i'm making it it's so rad to me
that the swimming pool
isn't even in the frame because it was
like so far away
but yeah i had to jump pretty far to
make it to the pool which i did
i had at this point already dropped out
of the university of miami
with no plan but to try to become a
famous crazy stuntman
and there was no precedent it was not
like a
it did not seem like a winning plan at
the time everybody i professed this uh
goal to just felt bad for me talk about
that journey like how did you get to
i want to be a professional stunt man or
even conceiving
of doing that how did you get into doing
stunts yourself like did you model that
off anyone or was it just you
and buddies [ __ ] around you know like
growing up from from being a
little kid i just everything was always
just like i was uncomfortable in my skin
and i would immerse myself
in like some sort of an identity
which made me feel like uh
you know like something i could cloak
myself in and at first it was
little league baseball you know little
league sports and i would uh
go around on days when i did not have a
game and i would be wearing my little
league uniform like going to the movies
or something because that made me a
baseball player and i felt like
you know like that's just what a kook i
was you know there was a uh
there was a picture when i was nine
years old for my canadian
citizenship i'm a triple national
because mom was born in canada dad was
born in the states and i was born in
england yeah i had to get a picture
taken from my canadian citizenship card
and that means i go into like the
passport office whatever taking the
photo
and i felt compelled to be wearing
full football uniform shoulder pads the
whole deal
like in my canadian citizenship card
there was no [ __ ] reason for me to be
wearing
my full football uniform with full pads
in a passport photo
but that that's the kind of kid i was
and
it made me feel like uh i don't know i
just needed that help
you know like to amount to more and i
always had a uniform like that and it
went from little league sports to
uh to heavy metal music i was like oh
yeah with my g
my jean jacket and my little mullet you
know like when i met motley crue in in
toronto because i called every hotel in
the yellow pages asking for a room by
the name of their manager
and uh so the heavy metal
you know identity like then it turned
into skateboarding you know and i really
did this and the skateboarding was the
biggest one
because it led me to the video camera
and and
what really made me fall in love with it
was that with the video camera
being such an attention [ __ ] i could
document what i was doing
and and edit out the uh failures
you know and so at the end of the day i
could like put together a presentation
of nothing but wins you know
and and that was something i really
clung on to and
lived in london england and went to the
american school and like all the skaters
and moved away or quit skating and
so i just gave up skateboarding for for
drugs
you know deliberately i was like my new
identity is going to be
a pothead you know druggie yeah that was
so that was another thing i wanted to
ask you about is like when did
weed alcohol any of that stuff come into
your life because you're sober now but
at that time it was so sadly deliberate
where i i dropped the identity of
skateboarder and just like that
now i'm going to be a druggie you know
like
and less than i wanted to experience
being high taking drugs i just wanted to
have that identity
that was when i was 16 the beginning of
my junior year of high school
and i just went off the deep and the
first day i tried pot
like uh then i it was an everyday thing
from that point
and then i started taking acid and i was
just you know and my grades just
plummeted i got into the university of
miami on
early acceptance which was the only way
i got in
and within two weeks of class starting
my freshman year at the university of
miami
i had my room raided they confiscated a
bunch of
weed and alcohol and everything they
they have placed me on
final disciplinary probation
within two weeks of class starting upon
my arrival
and uh dude and then then
and i failed so [ __ ] bad i had this
girlfriend
she was just observing me not going to
class
you know i just couldn't bring myself to
go to class
and uh she's like what are you doing you
know like what the [ __ ] you doing here
and i was just like i don't know you
know like
you're supposed to go to college so i
came right
and and and this is a story that i
really haven't told you know like um
she dumped me citing that she wanted
uh she was looking into her future it
couldn't see me in it
because she was observing how i was
approaching college and seeing she
determined i was going to be a loser
and she wanted to have things and so
it was over and i and i was just truly
heartbroken i was just like oh my god
and
and and and right around that time i got
kicked out of the dorms
there was it wasn't it wasn't final
probation anymore they're like no you're
out
you're right what was the [ __ ] were you
just caught partying again or
it was it was a good one it was a good
one like uh
and there's footage of it too i lived in
a
a 12 story dormitory which had a radio
tower
on it and um like
right at the top of the building in the
stairwell i broke out
the window and then climb it was like
the stairwell was separated by a balcony
i broke out the window
and climbed out over you know the gap
onto the roof
and uh then i was climbing up the radio
tower
and some some people saw me on the
ground there's someone climbing up the
[ __ ] radio tower on the 12th
and these cops came onto the roof
and and that was it for me um i was uh
at that point like um i had already been
dumped at that point
and i was like i was like [ __ ] i'm not
that good at skateboarding i love making
videos
i'm gonna be [ __ ] wild and i wanted
to be known that i was doing like
stunts that that i could die doing
you know i was i was climbing off the
the
12th floor balcony of that building just
dangling by my hands
like swinging out over like you know 12
stories just
holding the railing and then i would
swing in and let go
and uh land on the 11th floor balcony
you know
it was like [ __ ] up stuff like that
and i was drunk as hell doing it i did
it
i'd like non-acid for my university
career
i never once went to the library
except to repel off of it
[Laughter]
yeah i mean that checks out yeah and i
wanted this girl to be worried about me
like to think like oh he's gonna die you
know because he broke my heart
and then as i was doing all this stuff i
was like dude like i'm a stunt man you
know
have you been heartbroken before
prior to that so that was like your
first big
heartbreak it was my first like serious
heartbreak and like i was such a [ __ ]
creep man
i ended up dropping out of school even
though i would come back and live on
campus as a homeless person for the next
three years
and i just i was on this mission like to
make stunt videos
with a home video camera and and i
befriended the
the university of miami dive team it was
like an olympic factory you know and i
had the number one number two and number
three ncaa platform divers
all who shared an apartment in the
athletic apartments
and they'd like that they let me sleep
on their floor and like took me under
their wing and actually trained me to do
like you know acrobatics like walk
downstairs and upstairs on my hands and
do like you know back flips like really
pretty
you know well and i took that and i
started setting myself on fire and doing
simultaneous fire
breathing backflips like just kind of
putting my own twist on everything
and i was like man this is gonna i'm
gonna do this i'm gonna be like a rad
stuntman
and every year i would i would take the
footage i shot this went on for years by
the way too
like this went on into like 1998 and i
dropped out in 93.
every year i put i put together
a reel of the stunt footage the best of
for that year
and mailed it to that girl
oh my gosh yeah at her mom's house
i i'm literally just imagining her like
later
turning on tv and seeing you and being
like what the hell
is any of you i'm like i'm like i'm like
blushing i'm like
i'm embarrassed to admit this like what
if and she actually would
she would watch the videos and respond
and be like yeah that's really cool you
know like when
like yeah i can feel my face like it's
hot and red
well that's good that's that's actually
the point of this show
that's so funny and what what were were
you hoping
you said you were hoping that she would
see what you were doing and think that
you were
in danger but were you also like maybe
she'll think it's
cool i mean it was just about like
think is the same exact [ __ ] thing as
thinking that ripping my tooth out would
be perceived as
cool
yes i thought it was cool but it did it
wasn't perceived that way you know
you you've talked a lot about like
feeling out of
place out of sorts socially all of this
stuff
did you have a core crew like once you
were at the american school and stuff
like that did you
have a group of buds or were you just
kind of floating between
people yeah i mean i was able to like
just
sort of uh immerse myself in the in
whatever my identity was at the time
like there was a group of skaters and
and uh you know skateboarding was
actually the the
probably the best time for me because
it's just like a healthy thing you know
like i honestly believe that everything
that you know
they say you learn everything you need
to know in kindergarten and i
i say you learn it from skateboarding
you know i started skateboarding
in 1985 like within minutes of walking
out of the movie theater
uh having seen back to the future part
one
and i was like oh this is the coolest
thing and and because of back to the
future part one
like that christmas of 1985 pretty much
every kid in the world had a skateboard
oh yeah
and in short order a hundred percent of
those kids realized
wow skateboarding is incredibly
difficult and it [ __ ] hurts because
like uh
i'm you fall down you know i wanted to
get into skateboarding so bad because
again i'm like watching jackass i'm like
involved in the
culture of like punk pop punk emo music
i'm like i want to get into this
and then i could not handle the mental
like the mental block of falling down
skateboarding served to weed out it to
isolate
kids who were who who had it in them to
persevere
to sacrifice to like fall down and get
up to like
to go against the grain it's just like a
really
like pretty special driven type of kid
it's it's it's something that i care
about very deeply
yeah and you see a direct line between
you
being like you know what i'm gonna get
on this piece of wood that has wheels on
it and i'm gonna try to
i'm gonna try to flip on it and do all
this stuff
you can see a direct line to okay now
i'm scaling the library
and i'm not scared right and at the time
when i was scaling the library when i
when i got into all that you know
dropping out of college
um you know the whole thing with the the
girl breaking up with me
like that was another thing is it i was
like [ __ ] i blew it like i got to be
skating and i got back on the board and
i really
you know skateboarding has been a
constant actually like
in the last week i i was out there like
you know
really pushing myself and i learned a
new trick yeah
that's awesome i pulled a just pulled
off a trick for the first time in my
life
you know like within two weeks or so of
turning
46. yeah i feel like so many
people would let would like
mentally be like oh no skateboarding was
something i did when i was young and
it's like there's no reason to actually
feel that way like right um okay here's
what i want to do i want to go through
some of the pictures that you sent us
that we haven't talked about yet because
you had really good pictures so i just
want to make sure we talk about
so let's talk about this one we're
clearly rocking a look here
yeah this reminds me of another time
except it was my junior year
same exact dynamic as
the ripping out the tooth in fifth grade
but now it's 11th grade
it was the last class of the day a hit
of acid
took about an hour to to you know
make you start tripping you know i was
where you take it in about an hour
so i i walked into the final class of
the day
sat down next to the pretty girl turned
my head towards her and stuck out my
tongue and it had a hit of acid
on my tongue and she was just like
she was just like ooh creepy like
uncomfortable
awkward like you're [ __ ] weird
okay great now i'm trapped in class with
this guy who's tripping balls
right right and then the idea was that
when the class was over i
would not be tripping at school but i
could just like leave
it is very funny because i feel like you
can see
in that picture like obviously you've
got the long hair you've got the
necklace
this is my lsd uniform it was gonna yeah
i was gonna say i was like i feel like
we can see a really big difference
between the last picture
we looked at which is skateboard stevo
and now we're into
drug stevo and i think right
stylistically you're definitely
letting people know that that's where
you're going right
things are not going well
all right let's here we go okay so is
this university of miami
this is university of miami that picture
would have been taken
by the girl who broke my heart
oh my maybe not maybe not i don't know
but i spent more time at the pool
working on that
incredible tan than i did going to class
i was gonna say i'm like you're tan
you're fit he's ready for college
there was probably a class that i was
supposed to be attending
when that photo was taken and i was not
okay this
is a canadian passport i think
it is a canadian passport correct yeah i
i have three valid passports to this day
that's about as long as my hair ever did
get
and at what point what made you do the
bleach
because eminem was not in the picture so
what brought you to the bleach
at that point i was uh i just had the
government test drugs on me for money
and um was uh this was one of my things
that i did while i was homeless
um and uh i don't know i was just like
yeah i'm wild like
anything i could do just to seem you
know wild
what drug did what drugs did they test
on me it was called
uh rack dopamine hydrochloride
the study was that was trying to um
get fda approval for this drug to be
administered to pigs and cows
so that the so that the the pigs and
cows would have more muscle mass
and less fat so that the meat could
appeal to a more health-conscious
consumer
because in that scenario
people eat the meat a trace amount of
this drug would enter the human body
that required medical studies to
determine how much of this drug the
human body could withstand
or something like and uh and that made
it one of the more
risky you know like uh the more
dangerous the medical study the more it
pays
and uh they fed me and gave me a bed to
sleep in and i left with two grand
yeah i mean it's i i definitely get that
calculation so
we're coming to the end of our episode i
usually like to end by just asking our
guests
if you could talk to teen stevo today
what would you tell him what advice
wisdom
anything but i would say um
you know advice i want to be careful in
talking to
a teenage me about trying to
mess with the space-time continuum i
think that's great
be careful like if it's not [ __ ] i
don't i don't want to like
everything worked out i'm pretty happy
with it so i don't want to like
get and get too preachy on me but but it
would be really nice like it would just
purely
benefit to like take care of
your teeth and gums flo floss
and smell the floss make sure because
when people tell you have bad breath
that's what they mean
and so floss and
[ __ ] cigarettes and uh
and and don't put down the skateboard
you know just
skateboarding uh you don't have to be
competitive
in the big picture of skateboarding what
you have to
be is uh just just gotta
improve yourself you know only compete
against
you yesterday okay i love that
only compete against you yesterday
that's fantastic now i have one last
thing that i want to show you
okay um so the roast of your teenage
self it started as a
live comedy show where i have people
kind of show their pictures and roast
themselves and all that stuff
i have a photo that i show at every show
um
that i think sums up teen me here i am
with my jackass poster
in my insane high school bedroom um
you guys had the place of honor though
with this poster
it's great i remember i got it for
christmas
my parents didn't really understand what
it was
but but i got it anyway
um and it's yeah it's you guys alongside
pirates of the caribbean alongside sid
vicious harry potter just all the icons
of my childhood
yeah right on well hey i'm honored
and uh it's been a treat yeah it's been
truly amazing to have you
um and for everybody who's been
listening at home this
has been the roast of your teenage self
podcast
you